I'm in New York right now one of the
things I kept seeing is I saw a billion
dollar gym brand a multi-billion dollar
Apple brand a multi-billion dollar real
estate brand a multi-billion dollar
financial brand and ton of them not just
one or two right no one other thing to
have in common I walk around in New York
I see ton of pretty faces ton of pretty
girls good-looking guys well-spoken you
no swagger they'll approach you to flirt
with you you know they'll entertain you
you'll like them right and one of the
biggest challenges the majority have is
they don't know how to stay the course
there's a sign up there you won't be
able to see it right up here it says
Equinox celebrating 25 years of
commitment right Equinox gym when I
first came out gym memberships were 150
dollars and people said I would never
pay $150 they stay the course for 25
years now they're Equinox okay it's very
easy to be distracted by saying I'm
gonna get involved in this business I'm
gonna try real estate no no I'm gonna
try this oh no I'm gonna try that no I'm
gonna try this look pick one industry no
matter which one you choose it's going
to be difficult it's like no matter who
you ever date she's gonna be a pain in
the butt he's gonna be difficult that
tension whoever you ever date everyone's
gonna be fun for the first 30 60 90 days
then you'll learn about them ride the
acting is gone and you realize
everyone's got certain things you're not
gonna like upon it business is the same
way choose an industry choose occur you
give everything you got to it and do not
get distracted by looking at other
things staying aboard
close you stay the course though hey
stay the course greetings to everybody
from New York take care bye-bye